je suis une fois de plus ravi de vous
retrouver et j'espère que vous allez
bien que surtout vous continuez à
respecter les gestes barrière malgré
cette période déconfinement le virus
continue à circuler
soyons donc prudents et responsables
aujourd'hui nous partons en voyage
direction l'angleterre
on va retrouver elsa un gilet c'est une
martiniquaise particulièrement connu
dans le milieu de la mode et du
mannequinat
aujourd'hui elle a décidé de changer de
vie et de pays on la retrouve tout de
suite sur la première
[Musique]
samoans à voir c'est super beau derrière
on sent un graphiste a quand même bien
alors tu es une martiniquaise
particulièrement connu dans le milieu de
la mode du mannequinat et et modèle
photo et tout ça et là aujourd'hui ça y
est c'est fini tout ça est le
mannequinat ou décrit avec la pâte en
fait la demande de panneaux qui est
arrêté mais toujours dans les domaines
de l'image en matière va comme ça
derrière la pâte à quelque chose bon on
est content de te revoir dans un autre
lieu puisque aujourd'hui c'est à quitter
la martinique et tu vis en angleterre et
[Musique]
moi parce que j'ai dû poser la question
pourquoi pourquoi l'angleterre alors
première
pas mal d'entre nous il ya plusieurs
années au collège où j'ai pas vraiment
vu d'un botté de pays et j'ai l'occasion
d'y retourner à des retraites entre
temps en étant abri est vraiment à
chaque fois que j allais cnip en fait -
et tu fais quelque chose qui me reste
est vraiment en tête
c'est un rêve d'enfant donc qui s'est
concrétisée aujourd'hui une étape ça va
pas être évident quand même même si on a
on a tous à cette envie je pense à un
moment donné de se dire tiens j'aimerais
voyager vivre un an là deux ans là ça va
pas être évident de
de partir comme ça al aventure mais de
laisser ce qu'on a des acquis pour
démarrer une nouvelle vie ailleurs
comment est ce qu'on le géant ça vous
jeu des éléphants locaux appellent à mon
article je me suis beaucoup dans leur
authentique
donc du coup c'est vrai que tu es bien
avoir des contacts
quand on quand on prend payant de chemin
et pathé j'écoutais pas vraiment à me
fier j'ai juste fait attention à
l'essentiel pour que je sois pas pu être
organisée tout à l'heure je partage ma
fille dont il faut connaître le vent
maintenant et c'est à l'école et tout de
suite et est vrai qu'au fur et à mesure
pour mon chemin j'ai rencontré des gens
qui aient rencontré les gens qu'il
fallait alors tu nous parler de ta fille
comment ça se passe pour elle parce que
le fait de ne pas forcément parler
anglais
et d'arriver comme ça à londres est ce
qu'elle est dans une école française à
ce qu'elle se débrouille en anglais déjà
avant de partir une école anglaise et
j'ai été vraiment impressionnée par les
parcours d'évolution rapide et commence
à ne plus être au ralenti
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'on dit que
les enfants cette faculté à prendre lé
nombre beaucoup plus facilement que nous
ils ont un cerveau qui a encore un peu
plus souple le nôtre effectivement et
c'est bien parce qu'elle aura et laura
bat déjà cet avantage de parler
l'anglais couramment à l'issue de ce
petit séjour on la salue salut hors ue
avec l'accent plus à nador j'ai entendu
avec l'accent très bien très bien
la prochaine étape ce sera content parce
que tu nous disais que tu étais allons
mais que vont voilà tu tu arrêtais pas
forcément à ça est ce que tu as déjà en
tête d'autres pays qui te viennent
d'autres expériences que témoin vive et
excuser ni pour quelque chose de précis
en angleterre qui est pas encore je
quitte pas encore arrivé et enchaîna
paieront donc pour l'instant ce sont ces
qualités là il faut que je revienne
quand même en argot marmite comité
d'engagement là bas et puis à la panique
car milliers d'amis mais c'est vrai que
je porte clés à voyager
et alors les coûts présenté par l'inde
je fais pas pour les reds je pense et
puis est-ce qu'on peut donner ton site
internet ou les réseaux sociaux vont
pouvoir découvrir ce que tu fais ton
travail en tant que graphiste l'aigle
est le 2e est l inanité points comme les
quelques titres thalmann et taupe et
vous et puis au niveau ça va être un
travail personnel et du développement
personnel parce que halak tout que
l'effet que cali l'écouté de limiter que
j'ai pu faire jusqu'à aujourd'hui et les
personnes que j'ai pu rencontrer le
maître yoda partager ces moments de
partage et donc j'ai fait un blog sur
mon site personnel est l'un des points
comme vous pouvez le retrouver aux côtés
de piqué création les ailes ont été
ravis d'avoir des nouvelles de voir que
tu t'es pas nourris dans une nouvelle
vie en temps brasse très très fort en
tout cas prends soin de toi et de ta
fille également à très bientôt
si vous aussi vous avez des rêves
n'hésitez pas à les vivre même si
parfois ça implique de partir quelques
temps merci à vous de votre fidélité de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite sur martinique la première